now footballers are being criticized
after it emerged that under half of
players at many premier league clubs are
vaccinated against covid many are
reportedly refusing to be jabbed despite
next year's qatar world cup planning to
ban all unvaccinated players let's join
those guys [ __ ] marieke who's outside
tottenham hotspur stadium where of
course this afternoon they have been
playing aston villa
afternoon nick like you say that debate
now is just as important as the
positions players are taking on the
pitch a number of players in the most
recently announced england squad on top
of those premier league figures have
said or i have not taken the vaccine
about five of the players in the team
for the first time really we've had a
manager come out and speak out about the
responsibility he feels players should
take
in taking the vaccination that is jurgen
klopp the liverpool manager who had some
words about it earlier today
i don't take the vaccination only to
protect me i take the vaccination to
protect all the people around me and i
don't understand
where that is
a limitation of freedom
because if it is
if it is then
not being allowed to drink and drive
is a limitation of freedom as well but
we accept that we are not allowed to ask
people if they are vaccinated
but
am i i'm allowed to ask a taxi driver
are you drunk
and he said well i don't have to tell
you
and say okay then i don't drive with you
so no problem if i show up in the office
i'm drunk so then i can go they can send
me home or they can even send me but we
are not allowed to ask people i i might
be really a bit naive but i don't
understand it
so jurgen klopp there were some
typically spirited
remarks but i think it's quite
interesting speaking to fans here
there's a bit of a split some people say
players are role models for millions of
people therefore they should take the
job following government advice and
public health guidance whereas some fans
are saying it's an individual choice
here are some of the tottenham fans we
spoke to earlier at the grounds
we uh we sadly don't have those boxes
but i can i can i can summarize what
they said for you some fans were saying
that you know my young children come
here and they watch these players
they've been told that the vaccine is
important why aren't some of the players
doing it whereas we've also had some
people turn around and say that it's
quite important that people exercise
individual choice so this is a debate
that will keep on rumbling on i think